A story I never wanted to tell
our colleague and friend.
Drew Griffin
passed away over the weekend.
Drew, as you know,
was an outstanding journalist.
What you may not have known
is that he was an even better human being
and in this business.
TV journalism That is a rare quality.
And though he would hate to hear
anyone say it,
preferring that his work
say everything that needs to be
said,
Drew Griffin,
truly was one of the good guys, the best.
In fact, not just at CNN, but in life.
He was he was tireless.
He was honest.
He was self-effacing.
He was utterly devoted to his family.
Every producer who ever worked with him
will tell you that on the road,
Drew was always thinking
about the fastest
and best way to do the story.
So he could return home to them.
You do the work.
You do it better than anyone.
But he couldn't wait to get home.
And often his work changed.
Government is investigations
into charity.
Fraud
resulted in a nearly
$25 million settlement
with one of the largest direct
mail operators in the United States.
His investigations into the way
the Veterans Administration was run
sparked a complete overhaul
of VA leadership
to change the way veterans
receive the care they need and deserve.
Drew and his team earned a Peabody
Award for that work,
and he actually went to the ceremony.
One of the rare exceptions
he made to the life he preferred,
which was away
from the spotlight allergic to accolades,
but drawn to the work,
drawn to the cause
and the ones his work
truly counted so much for.
It showed in his talent
for getting people to talk to him,
which was frankly legendary, matched
only by his knack
for getting answers for those
who did not want
to give those answers to anyone.
Unless you've tried to interview
someone who doesn't want to talk to you,
you can't truly appreciate
how difficult it is
And Drew was a master, fearless,
even when the person in question
was a senator caught
in the act of doing the very thing
he had just spoken out against
getting cozy with high dollar lobbyists
after publicly chastising
that same kind of
business that, as usual,
Just want to ask you why
they're so important.
I mean, you're not the only guy
that does this.
But I
didn't really consent to an interview
right now.
And I
just wanted to ask you a few questions
about why you have these
in general,
why you have these kind of weekends
for these lobbyists who
politicians raise funds.
And this is what we do.
The way to do it.
You spoke
so eloquently about the disconnected
not being representative.
I just want it to like this.
I enjoy scale.
Thank you very much. Yeah.
Thanks.
A lot
As good as Drew was with the chase,
he was just as good at confronting lies
with facts.
Why do you continue
to push the lie
that the 2020 election was stolen?
A lie? It's a lie. You have no proof.
So we've looked at all the facts.
You don't have the facts.
Drew was
levelheaded, surefooted,
a truly genuine human being.
And in a business
where cynicism is paramount.
His sincerity shown through
his wife Margaret,
his three children, Ella Lui and Myles,
his two grandchildren.
You're all in our thoughts tonight.
Drew Griffin was just 60 years old.
Laura,
so important to really address
and think about his legacy.
And I just remember,
you know, I'm
I'm pretty new to this business.
And he would take the time
to write me
the nicest emails of encouragement
and just to say
words of wisdom, words of advice,
or just job well done
and to share and exchange
and the work
that he had done
as an informal mentor
in those ways
I'll never forget it
and I'll never forget the work
that he has done.
So I'm so glad to honor him tonight,
and I think I'll leave his family.
You know,
one of the things
I think about with him is
he had no partizan allegiances
whatsoever.
He didn't care
if you were corrupt or you were lying
you're full of crap.
He was coming after you.
It did not matter
what party you belonged to
or even if you belong to a party.
He didn't care.
The news continues
CNN Tonight with John
Berman is next right after a quick break.